the Trump administration seems jubilant
about the recent protests in Iran as I
said to the people of Iran almost a year
and a half ago the United States is with
you now the protests are being driven by
the economic situation GDP growth
projections are down by nine point five
percent inflation is it 40 percent and
unemployment is it 16 percent and rising
but it was a 50 percent increase in the
price of fuel that sparked the recent
turmoil
[Music]
now an economic squeeze like that is
bound to get people upset but why is
Iran in such poor shape well Donald
Trump has a lot to do with it
in 2015 the international community
agreed to lift decades-old sanctions in
response to an agreement that was
reached about Iran's peaceful nuclear
energy program but then along came
Donald Trump he decided to pull out of
the nuclear agreement he says that Iran
broke the spirit of the deal however
international observers say that Iran
fully complied as of today I can state
that Iran is implementing its new
candidated commitments after pulling out
of the deal the Trump administration
began imposing sanctions on Iran
intended to wreck their economy accusing
Iran of quote destabilizing activities
around the region the USA even
threatened to impose sanctions on other
countries that dared to buy Iranian oil
anyone doing business with Iran will not
be doing business with the United States
I'm asking for world peace nothing less
we're ready to impose sanctions on any
activity subject to restrictions after
the Iran nuclear deal in 2015
Iran was exporting roughly 2.5 million
barrels of oil per day now that number
is down to roughly 200,000 in a country
where the economy is centered around
state-run oil exports that's a pretty
big financial loss and it has been
detrimental cuts in fuel subsidies and
other benefits for the population had to
be made
sauron opal one top Iranian officials
have sat down and made a decision for
the country based on expert assessments
this decision must be executed but
according to Donald Trump working to
economically ruin Iran makes him the
best friend of the Iranian people
nothing says I love you like bleeding
someone drive you ask all nations to
support Iran's people as they struggle
to reclaim their religious and righteous
Destinee i want to deliver a message to
the long-suffering people of iran the
people of america stand with you well
the Iranian people return to the
nation's proud roots as a center of
civilization culture and wealth where
their people can be happy and prosperous
once again the United States throughout
the Iranian history has always been
against democracy I mean the United
States was the country together with
Britain that instigated the 1953 coup
against democratically elected Mohammad
Mosaddegh right now it's no different I
mean the United States has imposed very
severe sanctions on Iran which has hurt
a lot of ordinary people so coming out
and saying that they support these
people is hypocritical in the sense that
if you do support these people then you
wouldn't sanction them so hard that you
know they are having difficulty even
getting on with their daily normal lives
you